i just remember seeing the movie
serendipity but uh it is a miramax film
and and you know you wrote on instagram
recently about harvey weinstein he was
the executive on that he was the guy you
know in charge of that movie uh it came
out around uh right after 9 11. and the
whole cast got together and said i think
it's inappropriate for us to go out and
promote i mean me and john were just
like
absolutely not there's no universe which
we're walking down a red carpet in this
situation like it's it's insane
and we ended up having absolutely no
choice in that and i did feel really
uncomfortable about it and
was very concerned to not be
disrespectful and even though we you
know we were kind of forced to do it and
when you say forest harvey forced you to
like he said look i put a lot of money
into serendipity and uh you guys are
actors and you have better go out
you're going and and you know all the
agents were like okay you have to go you
know
and i wore um i wore a pursuit i just
thought we need to be a bit sober here
this is already so [ __ ] that we're
doing this
and i got in big trouble for wearing a
suit so
i got absolutely roomed for that harvey
reamed you for wearing a like pants uh
oh yeah i mean i was so shocked actually
because what a character he called up
and said
um we had kids the same age actually the
same name and everything and and he said
will you bring
you know will you bring your baby over
and have a play date with my child and
he'd never asked me to do anything like
that ever
and i again didn't feel like i could say
no and
so i turned up and he said you know
bring your nanny and so i
brought my friend uh kate and and the
minute we got in the door
he said okay
nannies take the kids off and they and
they and i thought [ __ ] what's happening
and then he just
went
insane you [ __ ]
stupid like i mean every horrible thing
you could possibly imagine at top volume
like
i [ __ ] paid you to
you know you if i say go on a red carpet
you shake your [ __ ] tits and ass and
you get down and it was
i was like
i was immediately in tears and shaking
because i you know i'd been brought in
on the pretext of the play date with
toddlers and suddenly i'm like
being screamed at that i'm a [ __ ] like
it was just like a lot
oh my god
feeling and you know i can you know okay
it's yelling and there are people who
had so many much more horrific
experiences but it was it was really
upsetting his mind is so bizarre to go
through the machinations of getting you
there with the baby making sure the
nannies are there then he's plotting to
get the nannies in the other room so he
can get you alone and call you a [ __ ]
[ __ ] for wearing a pantsuit when you
promote a movie there was some dark
stuff that i i was very upset by and
that was
revealing in terms of who he turned out
to be ultimately